este la última, es el dron submarino tridente,
es un submarino de buceo, es elegante, puedes ponerlo en una mochila,
puede bajar hasta 100 m, más profundo que la mayoría de los buceadores.
Puede ver estos entornos a los que la mayoría nunca han tenido acceso.
Nuevas herramientas están llegando y necesitamos herramientas aún mejores.
También podemos utilizar más filántropos visionarios.
Cuando Erik y yo empezamos esto, no teníamos dinero,
estábamos construyendo esto en su garaje.
Pero fuimos a Kickstarter.
Y encontramos más de 1800 personas,
recaudamos casi USD 1 millón en Kickstarter,
encontramos otras personas que piensan,
"Sí, esa es una buena idea.
Quiero ser parte de eso".
Necesitamos más formas para que las personas se comprometan.
y se conviertan en filántropos visionarios en sí mismos.
También tenemos filántropos tradicionales,
que han ofrecido financiarnos
en la iniciativa SEE, la Ciencia Educación y Exploración,
que nos ayudará a conseguir unidades donadas a las personas en el frente,
personas que están haciendo ciencia, personas que están contando las historias,
comunidades inspiradoras.
Pueden ir a OpenExplorer.com y ver qué está haciendo la gente,
es muy inspirador.
Y también, con suerte, lo estimulará a involucrarse.
Porque hay mucho espacio para involucrarse.
Queremos escuchar qué ideas tienen para contar estas historias.
Porque eso es todo, se trata de compromiso.
Hay todo tipo de formas nuevas e interesantes
para que las personas participen en la protección de estos lugares.
Y la comprensión.
Al igual que Reef Check, los buceadores bajan y nadan transectos.
y contando datos de peces y biodiversidad.
Están dando la información que necesitamos para proteger estos lugares.
Si van a la playa, participa en MPA Watch.
Documenten qué actividades ven en estas diferentes áreas.
Hay espacio para que todos participen aquí.
Y eso es justo lo que necesitamos.
Necesitamos construir un futuro para los nietos de nuestros nietos.
El mes pasado salí a navegar.
y salimos a las islas Farallon, a 40 km del Gate.
Y la mayoría la ve como una especie de santuario de aves,
pero tomamos nuestro robot, y lo enviamos.
Y la gente en el bote estaba asombrada por la vida debajo de la superficie.
Quiero decir, estos son ecosistemas muy, muy importantes.
Realmente, y este es un mundo salvaje que aún no hemos explorado.
Y ahora tenemos una oportunidad,
tal como lo hicieron hace 100 años,
proteger estos lugares, tener un plan, mantener a las personas comprometidas.
El año pasado, cuando salió la orden ejecutiva,
poniendo todo el progreso hecho,
todas estas nuevas áreas marinas protegidas, bajo revisión,
hubo más de 100 000 personas que comentaron en línea.
Casi todas estas cartas decían:
"No lo hagan; proteger estos lugares es lo correcto".
Mi mensaje a esas 100 000 personas, esas 100 000 cartas es:
No esperen a Washington.
Podemos hacer esto nosotros.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)